that's one of my favorite
uh jackass things where uh they
i forget what it was for but they were
gonna hit you i think with a fish
and it's really hard to stand there and
get it was for the super slow-mo camera
yes we did it for the intro right it's
is that what that was your intro shot
okay for though for the opening scene
and like and especially at like 1500
frames per second like you can catch
any little movement yeah and you got to
sit there
and get hit with a [__] fish in the
face like a big heavy fish
like it's really hard to know you're
going to get hit and not
not like flinch at all and so so they're
trying to get the shot
and and and you know your instincts like
you know you're like
you're kind of anticipating it it takes
four tries i know but they
four tries they said they said they said
uh stop moving man just just chill
and and you're like prince music and
they put on like some like iron maiden
or some black sabbath and you're like
you know it wasn't helping at all and i
was like hold on i got this
and i go running and getting my little
nissan verse and i pull it into the
[__] hanger
and i open up the doors and i play
christopher cross
sailing takes me away
[Music]
and all of a sudden you just relax and
like didn't move at all
i thank you for that because jeff was
getting pissed
he's like hey man just stand there
trying dude you know you see this like
right here is where you get the glitch
and that's where you move
right it's like when you were when you
were with us in thailand
filming wild boys and uh someone said i
think it was probably you you said
hey you know where we are and and i'm
like i don't know and you go
bangkok and [__]
and it was like the greatest nude shot
but somehow like they didn't get it
right on camera
so then so then it was like oh we gotta
reshoot it
but now all of a sudden we know that
we're going to get hit in the nuts
and it doesn't [__] work that way
dude yes
it doesn't did you guys ever get like
[__] epic footage that you never got
on camera and it's just like dude
if i only [__] had that on camera is
there any like thing that you
i think there's a car yeah i have a lot
of skate stuff like that
where we never had the cameras around or
rolled and i'm like damn
my worst injury ever oh yeah
yeah that's not on camera that's a
pisser get ready this is going to be
gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [__] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're going to hurt me you're going to
piss me off